Liv and Maddie was one of our favorite
Disney Channel sitcoms but as we re
watch it as grown-ups we can finally
understand what some of these jokes
really meant make sure you watch this
video until the end to know why we don't
really like to see Joey and Willow
together if you love Liv and Maddie as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we are showing you 5 funniest
adult jokes in Liv and Maddie you might
have missed the flirt in the fifth
episode Joey showed us what happens when
he is interested in a girl this time
everyone was getting ready for a
Halloween party and the young man
noticed a really cute girl that was new
to the school however he was not ready
to talk to her yet and this is why he
needed some practice girls first the
first thing he did was to use a weird
voice to tell her that if she were a
laser she would be set on studying then
at the Halloween party he asked a mummy
if she was from Tennessee because she
was the only ten I see
but he only managed to rip off her head
it didn't get better when he asked a
witch if she was thirsty but things just
got really weird when Maddie asked to
live to flirt with her brother because
he wouldn't recognize her in her mascot
costume we really cringed when he told
her that he couldn't keep wondering if
trapped inside that kangaroo was a
stone-cold Fox surprisingly it went so
great that he forgot about the cute girl
and wanted to ask out this kangaroo
instead it was the first time Maddie
played matchmaker and her brother wanted
to date their sister we just wish that
this thing never happens to us siblings
should never flirt together what would
you do in this situation don't be shy to
tell us in the comments the guillotine
in the third episode Maddie had to work
on a history assignment but she hasn't
done anything yet she thought that
watching lame Ezzor habla was enough to
know everything about the French
Revolution until she realized that this
project was worth half her grade this is
why she and Willow decided to submit a
visual representation of the era
instead of writing a 20 page report but
they couldn't just dress up as their
favorite characters they had to build a
real guillotine
and Maddy was really enthusiastic about
it they even used it to cut their
baguette for its crime against the state
having too many carbs and fat on izing
with English cheese but didn't they
realize that it was actually really
dangerous this thing was used to cut
heads and these two girls were playing
with it in their bedroom and there were
even a lot of kids in the house for a
sleepover when they were doing that
someone could have been hurt
Maddy even said that the young boys like
to smash things because they are
incredibly immature and that's exactly
what Willa was doing in the background
with the guillotine and the math
textbook we're happy that no one got
hurt in this episode except a fun
skeleton but we still think that it was
not appropriate to have fun with
something that was used to end people's
lives the mom jokes Liv and Maddie is a
great sitcom to watch with your parents
and that's because there are a lot of
jokes that only moms can truly
understand in the sixth episode Liv's
boyfriend just broke up with her this is
why her mother Karen was there to
comfort her lucky for Liv she was a
psychologist and she had two pillows for
her one that she could cuddle and
another that she could punch and she
admitted that she used it a lot when she
was dating their father so we imagined
that their relationship wasn't really
happy but the mom joke that we loved the
most was when Maddy asks for some twin
time and Karen said that she was there
for them during the 36 hours of labor
but she understood that it wouldn't mean
anything for them then an episode later
their father bought a barbecue that only
he can use and Karen said that this is
exactly what is happening to her with
the stove the dishwasher the dryer the
iron the vacuum and the toilet after
Parker uses it and just because the
mother is always here to make us laugh
she made another joke in the 12th
episode Liv got the lead role in a play
and she had to play a working mother who
struggles to juggle her career her home
and her kids the young actress thought
that she wouldn't be able to pull it off
and her mother said that she had the
same thought every day of her life these
are all jokes that only moms really
understand the health class in the 16th
episode of Liv and Maddie
Joey was wondering why he had a bad
grade in gym it was not a surprise for
us but he still needed to get better
because he wanted the perfect GPA this
is why he talked to his father
the coach who said that he got the grade
because he didn't finish the shuttle
race in less than 35 seconds he could
still take the test again if he wanted
to but he would only get one chance
after all his father doesn't make the
rules he just blows the whistle then out
of nowhere he told him that he also
teaches health class
so if Joey has any questions about his
changing body his door is always open
we don't ever want to hear our father
talk to us about this we'd rather hear
what a professional has to say
but unfortunately for Joey his father is
the professional at school so he's going
to have him as a teacher to learn about
the birds and the bees this joke came
out of nowhere and we didn't expect his
father to talk about the S word in gym
class no matter what he didn't talk
about it after so everything was fine
for Joey but he still had to find a way
to run faster and Willow was there for
him the crush since the second episode
we understand that Willow had a crush on
Joey a huge crush unfortunately she
wasn't really good at flirting when she
first talked to him she said that she
hearted him and claimed that he was her
property so no one could ever look at
her man in the third episode she had a
notebook full of love notes - Joey in
the 8th episode she asked him if he
wanted to be sketched by her art class
and she promised that this time it was
the real thing as most models have to
pose naked for this kind of class we
just hope that this is not what she
meant
anyway she just forced him to follow her
she also bought all the things that Joey
used to have in the yard sell and even
tried to fit his retainer in her mouth
in the last episode of the first season
she even paid Parker to trap Joey in a
harness so she could go on a date with
him they ended up together at the end
but we still think that we shouldn't
teach kids that they need to harass
people until they date if a guy was
doing that to a girl we think that much
more people would think that that's
inappropriate
are there any adult jokes that you heard
and Liv and Maddie don't be shy to tell
us what you think in the comment section
we'd love to hear from you and that's it
for 5 funniest adult jokes in Liv and
Maddie you might have missed for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
funniest jokes in Jesse you might have
missed thanks for watching
[Music]